laughs
so
it's been a little while
since I've made
one of these
Direct
messages
on the YouTube channel
been about
a year or so
and
it's been great
It's Been instrumental
in
deepening
silence
realization
integration
and dissolution
of all projection
of all falsity
of all fabrication
because there's only
you
ultimately
there's only you
the absolute
foreign
which means
you don't have to do anything
to
be
the Indescribable Perfection that you
always already
are
and they're all
always only forever
be you
in all these beautiful
wild explorations
with yourself
foreign
it means that
right here
right now
absolute peace and perfection
happiness
that is normally sought
externally
in objects
and a appearances and
experiences
can be found
right here
right now
absolute highest
peace
happiness
and perfection
but the cultural conditioning is so loud
foreign
that you have a sense of self
that everyone around you has a different
sense of self
that those are others
that you're located in the body they're
located in their bodies
that you all have identities
that you're attached to
that you feel some sense of lack
and then that shows up
in all of the various ways that we
behave
the governments the economies the
nation-states
the propaganda the social media
all of it is just
extracting you from yourself
the self
with a capital s
God
the kingdom of which is within you
foreign
when you
finally
desire
to let go of all of that noise of the
illusion the projection The Mirage
the fabrication the stories the
attachments
stations
what happens when you let go of the
little games that you're playing with a
sense of self a sense of others
positioning
lack
what happens when you become space
consciousness
locationless identity less
do you then finally for the first time
actually
taste and feel
what love
actually is
and there is only that
everywhere
is only that
you
there are no others
there's never been
another
there's only been
you
everywhere
and nowhere
the greatest liberation
actually
of being nobody
of being nowhere
and therefore being everybody and being
everywhere
when you are empty of self
you are full of wholeness of God of the
absolute
oh
so be patient
and be immediate
patient
with not necessarily always immediately
speaking about realizations
learning to be silent learning that
they're made just for you
and allowing them to integrate
in that spaciousness
and also learn to be
immediate
right here right now
learn to feel
the spacious nature of mind
but the mind is literally made of the
same air
that you perceive as outside of you
that all mind
is
made of that same air
immediate right here right now
just see what illusion are you
fabricating
that is preventing you
from seeing
that
mind is made of air is made of space
is spirit is formless
is consciousness is infinite
there's only you
what illusion are you fabricating that
is preventing you from seeing that
construct the [ __ ] out of that
both with great excitement
yet patience
subtlety nuance
and yet also immediate
very life
may all
be happy liberated
prosperous
peaceful
joyous
and abundant
it's our true nature